أنا لست محبطًا لأنني رأيت استطلاعًا للرأي
مؤخرًا أظهر أن ما يقرب من
99٪ من أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي لم يدعوا
إلى
وقف إطلاق النار ولكن ما يقرب من 70٪ من الأمريكيين
يريدون وقف إطلاق النار
من كلا الحزبين السياسيين ومن
كل مجموعة عرقية تقريبًا
الجنسية الجماعية، الإيمان، الدين، لذا فإن ما
نراه حول العالم، وليس فقط في
الولايات المتحدة، هو
فجوة هائلة بين جماهير الناس والقادة
الذين تم
انتخابهم أو تعيينهم، وهناك
خيبة أمل شديدة، ليس فقط بالنسبة لي،
فقد توقعوا شخصًا ما  للظهور ظنوا أن
بعض الحكومات وبعض الدول وبعض
المنظمات وبعض
الهيئات الدولية أحد الجيران اعتقدوا أن شخصًا ما
سيتدخل لقد
رأيت آباء وأمهات مع أشلاء من
أطفالهم يبكون أمام الكاميرا سايانغ
يسمون القادة بالاسم قائلين أين
أنت كيف يمكنك أن تتركني  هنا لا أستطيع،
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل
اليأس من تحمل الكثير من العنف
كل
يوم وبدأت أتساءل هل صحيح
أنه لن يحضر أحد
وأعتقد أن القادة جميع القادة في جميع أنحاء
العالم يجب أن يخجلوا أنا أشعر بالخجل
بالنسبة
لهم